Hello there!
Today we are going to talk about positional
embeddings.
You should have heard of them, because
wherever you see a transformer neural network,
you also see positional embeddings attached
to them.
And because transformers are now literally
everywhere in machine learning, irrespectively
of the data type, you should have come across
positional embeddings already.
But what are positional embeddings, why do
we need them in transformers in the first
place, and how do they work?
Well, today we are going to lift the mystery
over positional embeddings.
Transformers are more and more important for
machine learning and have been proven to work
very well on any kind of data, especially
when there is a lot of it to pretrain through
self-supervision.
A big part of the data that we are interested
in,
comes in a specific order.
If we change this order,
the meaning of the input might also change.
The transformer does not process the input
in order, sequentially, but in parallel.
For each element, it combines information
from the other elements through self-attention,
but each element does this aggregation on
its own,
independently of what the other elements do
or have done yet.
Because the transformer architecture per se,
does not model the order of the input anywhere,
we must encode the order of the input explicitly,
for the transformer to know that one piece
comes after the other and not in any other
permutation.
This is where positional embeddings come in:
They are sort of an identifier, an obvious
hint for the transformer encoding the whereabouts
of a piece of the input within the sequence.
These embeddings are
then added to the initial vector representation
of the input.
This addition can be intuitively understood
as:
look! the initial vector representation of
the word “queen” is here in the multidimensional
space.
It is close to “king”, because of word
frequency distribution reasons -- king and
queen often occur in the same context.
But then, we add this positional embedding
identifying the order of the word.
Hereby we say: “queen” should move a bit
along this dimension towards this specific
part of the space to cluster with all the
other first tokens in any other sequence.
Space and dimension which we do not really
have in this 2d drawing, but you get the idea
that by adding these vectors we move the initial
representations into the direction of the
other first tokens, or the second tokens,
and so on.
At least, this is how Ms. Coffee Bean pictures
it and you will possibly ask:
But how can this little multi-dimensional
shifting help the transformer?
Well, remember we are working with a multi-dimensional
spurious correlation identifying beast
which is a neural network,
therefore why should these systematic shifts
not be enough of a hint for it?
So, in short, positional embeddings are order
or position identifiers added to vectors for
the transformer to know the order of the sequence.
These positional embeddings, must fulfil some
requirements:
First, every position should have the same
identifier, irrespectively of the sequence
length or of what exactly the input is.
So while the sequence might change, the positional
embedding stays the same.
Secondly, because the embeddings push the
original vectors by a bit into let’s say…
the “first token club”,
they should not be too large,
otherwise they push the vectors into very,
very distinct subspaces where the positional
similarity or dissimilarity overtones the
semantic similarity.
Okay, then let’s see the solution to this
problem, as presented by the “Attention
is all you need” paper introducing the transformer.
Their choice of positional embeddings is not
the easiest one and is best understood if
you have some knowledge of Fourier analysis.
But let’s forget about that and explain
it simply:
You could think of the sequence as words coming
in one after the other.
So the first idea is to take a non-periodic
function and number your sequence from 1 to
the total number of tokens you have.
But with this recipe, we violate the second
requirement of positional embeddings, where
we said that shifts should be small, in other
words: bounded.
Then let’s choose a function that is bounded
in the values it can take, like the sine or
cosine, periodically returning to values between
1 and -1.
Sines and cosines have the upside that they
are defined up to infinity, so even with enormous
sequence lengths, we would still have something
between -1 and 1 as elements for our positional
embeddings.
In comparison to a sigmoid, which is also
bounded, sines and cosines have a lot of variability
also for big numbers.
Okay, so let’s choose a sine function to
model this.
But we see that with this periodic function,
the same outcome would repeat for different
positions.
Let’s suppose for a moment that we do not
want that and give our sine function such
a low frequency, that even for our biggest
sequence length, the numbers would not repeat.
With this, we almost have the same situation
as our linear function, because we numbered
our sequence in order, but this time, with
unique values between 0 and 1.
This is still not optimal because we remember,
our positional embeddings push the input a
bit, to create “positional clubs”.
But we also do not want to push by too much,
because otherwise distances between points
become dominated by the position and not the
semantics.
We also don’t want too little differences
between the first or the second token, because
in this case, the semantic signal would overtone
the positional embedding signal that now contains
values that differ very little between let’s
say the first or the second token.
So what to do?
If one value in one dimension is too small
of a signal, let’s make our intent more
obvious by using all the other dimensions
too!
For the next dimension, we could use a cosine
which would look like this.
Yet we still have the problem that embedding
values between one token and the next one,
do not differ by much.
But if we increase the frequency of the cosine,
the values differ more, because the slope
has increased!
Okay, so for this second dimension, let’s
use a cosine with increased frequency to create
more differentiated values.
The second and first dimension together are
uniquely differentiating tokens one from another,
but now also with values that differentiate
consecutive tokens more.
And if we do this for every dimension, meaning
that we
alternate between sines and cosines with increasing
frequency,
we give enough information to ensure that
the transformer cannot miss this order of
the sequence.
So to recapitulate what we did: The last dimension
tells us broadly where the token is, like
is it more at the beginning or more toward
the end of the sequence.
But because the values are so continuous,
we do not have enough resolution to say if
it is the first or the second token exactly.
Then the second to last dimension has higher
frequency, thus higher resolution.
Because we already know that we are at the
beginning of the sequence, we can pin down
with more accuracy where we are exactly.
The next dimensions pin down with even more
acuity where we are in the sequence.
Well, this was the sine and cosine way of
encoding position.
But this is only one way to do it.
This sine and cosine embedding seems to work
well on text,
but what if you have other types of data?
Like graphs.
Or images!
Let us know, would you be interested in Relative
Position Representations and / or learned
positional embeddings?
If yes, write us in the comments and I could
convince Ms. Coffee Bean to cover this in
one of our very next videos!
Or let us know in the comments about any other
exotic or not-so exotic positional embeddings
you would like to know about.
Ms. Coffee Bean, why are you poking me?
Aaa, thanks for reminding me!
We now have a Patreon page and Ko-Fi page!
So if you want and have the means to support
us, now you can!
We would greatly appreciate it!
But if you can’t, it’s fine, it does not
change anything.
Our videos will stay free to watch for everyone!
Okay bye!